Performance and
speed is something that user love.
In order for
us to see what our performance is,
we need to look at the speed report.
Speed reports show us how different
request took in our app or site.
You may want to track how quickly the
screens for each new level of the game
load, or how fast search result have
been brought back to the user's page.
You could also toggle between
different version of this report, and
I'll show you what to gain from the
distribution, and the overlay reports.
By the way, this report is important
enough to be taken to the dashboard so
you can face it on a daily basis.
In my last startup,
we also sent it on a weekly basis.
So we could see if and
how we improving after each new version.
The main metrics that you gain from
this reports is definitely to see
what is the average load
time of each and every page.
And here you can see that I
definitely had a problem with my site
at the beginning of last May.
When we clicking on
the Distribution tab of this page,
we could definitely see what is going
on in different buckets, and that could
help us a lot to identify problematic
sections or buckets in our site.
Another very important aspect of this
report is to go to the Map Overlay.
It's important because
we want to see how
different users around the globe
are using and leveraging our site.
What is the global distribution,
let's say of the average user timing?
We could see here that the darker
shades indicates longer load time.
This report can show if your app or
site experience got any issues on
particular geographic regions.
It's especially important
if you are using CDNs or
stream content that depends on
a geolocation of your users.
Here for instance, you can see that
I clearly got some problems in Chile.
And luckily in the States and Canada,
and over Europe,
I'm quite in a good position.